moth Gideon you have something I want I
like to think that he wants to be able
to tell people how they should live
because the world's in chaos and moth
Gideon in his brain thinks he's
completely within his right and the law
he's neutrally lawful you are not worthy
of my respect boy Stan Edgar company man
he is the guy who is in charge of these
superheroes on the boys I have a feeling
about corporations I'm gonna say he is
lawfully evil perfect for Stan he uses
the law to bolster his position and his
power my name is Gustavo but you can
call me Gus Gustavo Frank evil villain
but in my head he's doing something for
a reason he is neutrally evil why
neutral because he is so comported and
so cool and such an observer of all of
people's attitudes and emotions and he's
a manipulator when I think about all
these great characters I played I think
about their intention what do they
really want there's good and evil out
there all the time you make a choice to
be one or the other fortunately for me I
can make so many different choices and
have fun doing